ora i dati sulla seconda mappa di yum
full flat ragazzi questa qua è l'ultima
che non corrono non è stata vista nel
suo video speriamo vada bene perché i
miei compagni non sono così
collaborativi o forse sì
buona visione abbiamo andiamo unite come
faccio
no aspetta aspetta che la smetta parata
far spetti aspetti matadi la aiuto penso
sia lei mi sta cavalcando signor gatto
allora io so io so io devi camminare su
questo coso qua ma non credano spingere
non spinge re dello swing di questo
gioco ti muovi semi spingi malati
sorgendo questo qua dove siamo questo
qualora dove sono io adesso devo andare
aspetti che vedo è vero siamo dei
cretini
siamo scemi dirlo prima era una cacata a
dire però che noi abbiamo fatto bene lei
c'era quasi riuscito a farlo abbiamo
rotto il ma dai è stato bravissimo
ragazzi alla diavola scorsa alla fine
quindi scusatemi ma secondo me ce l'ho
scoperto subito provento nulla fino alla
piana diabete ma brown aveva allora
diventa una grandissima mischia siamo
sempre tutto dipende da noi non lo
prendo io qua e là xavi porca vacca
troppo ma quasi
c'è una merello e su quali sono ragazzi
sopra dove qua qua qua io ho un tubo
signori ecco girato ancora di più facile
eccolo fermi per me ma io mamma mio
maestro bravissimi mi serve il tubo
cerca un tubo la leva ragazzi
lieve verde maritati di profilo ok
picchiata ok bomba mila ragazzi a
funzionario tecnologia madonna
bravissimi andiamo portiamo in giro
grazie per manina via ca miseria che
dobbiamo tutti quanti insieme andare
però giu adesso dovresti dovresti
buttare giù di cose e far roteare
l'arsiam ufficio a fermina per il primo
tricolore non sono tantissimi di non
fare comunque ciao e grazie
intanto vediamo di fare allenare questo
li poi da di ma non ci arriva
aiuto aiuto benissimo bravo ragazzi la
mappa ancora lunga ma l'edizione non è
così difficile ti spingi spingi lega
prendetemi per un secondo ho visto
giusto insieme al tunnel al barile
vai spinge telefonica e volée lo
prendiamo noi facciamo direi provo
maurice preso cc aiuto il credito a
livello mameli 4 non si può
no e sei pazzo non funziona una
brevissima bravissimo conosce la fiat
grazie due ore basta ragazzi ed
interessati incredibile anche perché non
avrei mai fatto tutto quello che ha
fatto lui quindi credibile la porti però
se si mette in mezzo alle balle alla
mano
no non tiravano asca girate
bella ma mi dà la mano no no no no non
può con la mia testa è salito al gatto
facciamo allora finora è stato tutto
semplice quindi come tutto semplice
sostanza degli esami guardi poi
succederà questo la donna tra vista se
mago ravo li avrà è veramente bravissimo
e show già saving time saving svagata
miticamente amiche amiche amiche
tiramisù non staccarlo no pedala tieni
prendi questo ma no prendi me
ok entriamo in treno altre volte cos'è
sta roba c'è un fuoco si può uscire
se ti che ha ottenuto figata quasi un
coso con se non lo raggiungerò mai però
il coso non preso solo bravissimo un po
più usati credito ma il fatto loro
non lo so può 66 problemi da un altro
sailing malato l'altro saving sono
fortissimo a noi dobbiamo salire su sto
coso rosse sullo sfogo guarda guarda
guarda e vota
niente stai facendo cose con tubo lo so
sono fortissimi sono state che sono
quattro secondi posti
grazie serve un pezzo di tubo al piano e
lei fa casino linsailing se poi si può
buttare no perché lo devo portare
indietro poi e non c'è il sailing scopo
continuare di qualche troppo emotiva a
livello ma saving se si butta là dove
siete voi amici medico a porta quel tubo
di m m qua mamma mia ragazzi ho fatto
ragazzi sono fatto o il tubo e per travo
e allora vieni qua passato vero che è un
attimo che dovevo capire come torna
linea dovrebbero lancio sì se ho capito
guardi apro lancio venga l'angelana
lancio ma che lancio che quel casino
aspetti aspetti che venga qua veloce
stavo cadendo di sotto
ahia
mi ha detto di prendere questo tubo per
oasi metta apprende il tubo ma che tu
povero salire sopra prima come lo porti
dietro un apporto di sopra il tubo io mi
aspetta
ma se tu sali poco mercato dove lotti ok
ci sono sono ragazzi mentre voi vi state
ammazzando ho capito come camminare come
un cane ragazzi
vieni qui vieni qua quindi qui non ci
arrivo io lì quindi qui sotto e mano
come se prendi il nuovo chi lo prende
vita chiusa lì sopra quello di prendi a
mamma mia aspettami ora mi aspetto il
secondo io salgo io è stato spararmi il
tubo veloce e proprio dammi il turbo al
rimpatrio sopra e mi ha incastrato
no mai castrato l'ha incastrato l'hanno
incastrato su che ha posto tra gli gira
gira dyck lasciò la e non vedo più
niente
stia tranquillo ci siamo siamo ci siamo
e cosa li leggo io ho che l'ambito
premio casinò tieni tubo lei è pazzo lo
prende e non solo è un po più su più
sudditi bravo va bene no ma questo si
muove la neve si muove sia ferma un
attimo ok dove si prende questo problema
allora non è facile ok sto ma dovranno
un colpo pesante di me ma signor gut
equa e certi signori adeguati che sta
pilotando via tranquillo secondo me
bisogna sognare di comprendere quel
latte su quella far cosa che si chiama
nella catena
aspetta aspetta
ecco bravo così o così stai così un
attimo no allora cercato venga qua mi
prenda chi non vuole entrambi di là che
fate un po da contrappeso vediamo se
riesco a salire come
funzioni contrappesi vediamo aggrappati
pietro come capita cosa di un tubo in
mano ma in tutto questo ciccio nobel a
prendere tu hai visto l'hai preso mikel
avevo preso però la corona che tipo si
abbassa per caso anche 9 al sicuro sono
malattia ovviamente allora arrivano sala
con aria e perché io sono intelligente
faccio qualcosa nel mentre vi questo qua
c a rischiare e non lo so cosa fa aiuto
funziona e rischiosi e molto sia ferma
aiuto c'è un tubo qua ho trovato c'è un
tubo hanno avuto giu ma è ora che
funziona che arrivò pieni e quello a cui
è un tubo 4 quello serve per l'economia
serve parlare che ora più veloce sto a
fare qua a guarda guarda che questo tubo
servili questo tubo no non regga al
contrario ragazzi nostro centro è il
contrario
ok ok e ci sarebbe il mio sarebbe il mio
lavoro per nulla noi ve le siete proprio
degli stolti e se non ci fossi io
madonna veramente sia negato mi scusi
lei a dire che all'inizio questo aspetto
aspetta si no ap si ok la ruota adesso
adesso andate talmente veloce che tipica
capitarti dentro icoso sono entrato che
forte a posto sono dell'aiuto maestro
raduno è crollato tutto è crollato tutto
il corso è crollato
quindi e quindi si arrivò no arrivo
anche io mi chiedo dov'è questo di
quattro ragazzi c'è un problema mi dica
la ruota non c'è più la ruota e vediamo
c'è più la moda dovessi se così è
successo come possibile ma dice simbolo
dell'uscita che
alla fine no no cvd ragazzi questa era
l'ultima mappa di iowa for flat per
adesso ci sono anche quelle su steam
workshop di ne faremo altre sicuramente
fatemi sapere se vi piace questo team
che stiamo portando avanti a me
personalmente piace sono tutti molto
bilanciati tranne uno e come se i
ragazzi video scrivere sul tasto mi
piace e mettere un commentino qua sotto
su cosa ne pensate del video che cosa
pensate potremmo fare per migliorare il
prossimo e noi ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo video
[Musica]